the saints already are in
and there's an interesting question
about the future of the quarterback
position after
drew brees we have assumed that it will
be taysom hill based upon what we've
seen from taysom hill even with a not
great game on sunday against the eagles
because let's face it not every
quarterback is great every single week
we still assume that taysom hill will be
the starter sean payton recently
addressed this i believe this was on the
huddle and flow podcast we do not have
the sound okay apparently and i'm going
to paraphrase i don't have the whole
context but what peyton said is
that jameis winston
is going to have the opportunity to
start the minute that minute that drew
brees leaves that is confusing to me
because first of all winston's only
under contract for one year
and we don't know that bruce brees is
definitely gone after this year and even
if brees is gone you have to re-sign
winston before he can compete to be the
starter you know i feel like at a
certain level this is an effort to
ensure that both hill and winston decide
to stick around we saw teddy bridgewater
stick around for a couple of years they
still need to have a backup a quality
backup behind taysom hill if he's the
starter and uh maybe they can convince
jameis winston to stay thinking that he
will have a chance and maybe he will
have a chance to compete to be the
starter so i just think all of that's
premature
but i can see why sean payton would want
to keep jameis winston around because
he's shown he can be a good quarterback
and you need to back up the taste some
hill if taysom hill is the guy sharing
and absolutely mike nothing has changed
for jameis winston between the end of
last season and right now i mean he's
only played three games he's seven of 11
for 75 yards does that convince a team
that hey he's going to be our starting
quarterback next season i don't think it
convinces anyone other than saints who
have seen him day after day after day in
practice those 30 interceptions still
linger and are going to be attached to
him going forward and i don't know if a
team is going to be willing to roll the
dice on that and commit money to jameis
as their starter knowing that he threw
those 30 interceptions last season but
he also threw for 5 000 yards last year
and i and i know that sean payton sees
that and he's seen him in practice every
day and if he likes jameis winston he's
going to talk him into coming back just
like he talked teddy bridgewater into
coming back it worked out great for
teddy bridgewater and that's what sean
i'm sure is going to tell jameis look
this worked out perfectly for him he
came back and backed up and and if brees
retires you'll have a chance to start
and play and then a year from now you
can go and be a starting quarterback
somewhere else if that happens or be our
starting quarterback going forward if it
works out here but i do see jameis
winston going back to the saints because
i think that's the best move for both
teams but sean payton is one of the rare
coaches in this league mike
who really plans ahead i don't maybe
that's the not the right term to use but
i like the way he does the quarterback
position he always has a veteran back
there that he really trusts
behind drew brees he has a starter and
then he has his backup who's really good
that can come in and win games and then
he usually has a third guy that can come
in and win games too and it's the only
team i can think of that has those three
quarterbacks and all three of them can
win games for you and he's shown that
year after year after year when brees
has gone out of the lineup they continue
to win games what are they now they're
now eight and one over the last two
years without drew brees at quarterback
this is a team that will compete again
next year no matter who the quarterback
is all the more reason to have a great
backup too we've seen how taysom hill
plays taysom hill plays hard taysom hill
could get injured and you need to have
somebody who's ready to go drew brees
got injured and he doesn't play with the
level of aggression and uh physicality
that we see from tyson who on a
continuous basis so they're going to
need to be ready in that regard there's
no reason to close doors especially now
you close doors on guys in the off
season you don't close guys on
doors on guys who are on your roster
during this season and for now winston's
surely a viable candidate for the future
regardless of whatever plan sean payton
has what else is he going to say no that
that wouldn't that wouldn't go over well
for the guy that you still may need to
come in and play at some point
before the end of the season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports